marketing for the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now marketing for the now
10 minutes 12 remarkable guests
for two hours answering a singular
important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hi everyone welcome back to marketing
for the now
2.0 gary it sounds like you you were
ready before are you ready now to just
dive right in
i like how that video ended because like
literally when you asked me there
and that was the video part i literally
sat here while
taking care of a client issue on andrea
and said
i'm always ready and then you are ready
i'm ready and the lineup
kudos to you and the team today is a
remarkable day
hello everybody i know we're streaming
these on all my channels so let me say
what's up to the vayner nation
very very fast paced the way i like it
off of something very specific
you can see this up here right now the
question of the day
andrea i don't know if there's anything
else you want to do get the intros going
but i know this is going to be massively
rapid fired and i'm very excited about
it
yeah you got that right the only thing
is we'd love for everybody to chime on
in with any kinds of questions so
hashtag marketingforthenow
and we're gonna just jump right in first
up we've got none other than kevin
o'leary
he's not only the star of abc's shark
tank
he's an active photographer a watch
collector
guitarist and author of three
number one best-selling books welcome
kevin great to be here thank you so much
kevin it's a real real real pleasure to
have you here um
first of all have you done through this
pandemic both on a personal level and
maybe
a macro kind of like a business level
you know because this pandemic has
created a lot of
you know winners and a lot of losers
it's been very all over the place
you have a vast portfolio you know how
are you
and then kama how was your business
world well
you know gary that is the question for
everybody in america today and you're
right there are winners and losers but
you know personally i'm adjusting just
like you are to living a world in a
digital way just
every day i communicate as we are right
now and
all of my companies i have over 50
portfolio companies now
um have gone through this incredible
transition to what i call the digital
pivot
america 2.0 the ones that have survived
um you know first of all we've we've
gone through this seven months now have
been able to tell a story
online shift to direct to consumer sales
become very proficient at logistics
and have been able to just take away
what they lost from
retail sales and sold it direct to
customers so in this crazy outcome that
i could have never foreseen
80 percent of the portfolio even though
revenues are down
are actually ahead of free cash flow
forecasts
why because they've gone from just doing
10
direct to consumer to doing 40 to 50
direct to consumer
at almost 100 gross margin and they've
saved their companies
now the ones in travel the ones in
entertainment the movie theater
businesses
uh the weddings those those the live
event stuff
i'm sorry they're going to zero and
that's 20 of my portfolio but 80
that's fantastic they're going to make
it so let's frame up the question that
this whole show is going to be about and
we have an incredible lineup starting
with you
where where is the customer's attention
how do you synthesize that question and
what is the answer well never in our
lives gary have we had the opportunity
to have such a captive customer
they are sitting at home just like you
and i are they are looking to be
entertained
communicated with they are willing and
able to
purchase products and services but they
want it done conveniently and delivered
directly to them
they are not going to go get it anymore
this is the
digitization of america in a very fast
way
and what i've learned and this is really
binary
i used to have this joke gary i used to
tell people what career should you have
and i'd say well there's three careers
if you're going to go to college and
invest in yourself
engineering engineering and engineering
but now you know who i'm hiring story
writers videographers photographers
editors i'm i'm having to compete all
around the world to hire some people in
israel in italy and france to cut video
because all of my companies are telling
stories on their websites
and so we have now empowered a whole new
generation of artists who are doing
phenomenally well
that i would have never guessed
storytelling direct communications with
your customer
compelling them to watch that 1920 39 49
second video
that communicates what your product or
service is is what the successful
companies are doing and we are spending
millions of dollars doing this digital
pivot
obviously because of dragon's den and
then shark tank you're
you have a personal brand how would you
the human because you're talking you
know
obviously as you can imagine i'm
listening to the first five minutes of
this
conversation i've been spending the last
11 years building a communications death
star
to do everything you just talked about
because i basically believed that the
internet was going to squeeze the middle
everything was going to be direct to
consumer whether that's ott or
e-commerce and that the ability to
storytell and run the arbitrage on the
distributions
was actually the game so i like those
chess moves of how they played out to me
i'm curious because i'm sure a lot of
people who are watching are curious
right now
what about you yourself within social
media
have you in these nine months because
i'm sure you've been busy
helping mentoring like i'm sure you're
on constantly on calls with
entrepreneurs
of these 50 plus businesses but what
about you and your own personal brand
have you picked up a platform have you
started to use
linkedin from a content standpoint have
you
downloaded tik tok where are you the man
you the shark you the
people where do you sit personally right
now with
with social or content creation whether
first party
because you grab the phone and do it or
whether you live a little bit of the
game i play
i have drock ironically is here for the
first time in seven months
have somebody producing for you you the
personal brand what's the production
around that if
anything you know gary you are the role
model for guys like me
you got it right you guessed it right
the middle did get squeezed out there's
no question and i really got involved in
social about two and a half years ago
and i hired a team of producers editors
and storytellers
to work within my own production company
larry productions
and what i learned and this is the
paramount maybe
maybe i'll give you credit for this
because certainly watching you
you cannot [ __ ] people you can't
lie to them you have to be totally
transparent
whether that's good bad or ugly you got
to tell the truth
that is what a personal brand is built
on the minute it's almost like
the analogy i use and i teach this stuff
now i'm here in boston i do
i used to do lectures in person but now
i do them virtually at harvard and mit
and temple
and notre dame and i talk about this
stuff primarily the graduating course of
business students and engineers about
entrepreneurship
it's like dating you know when you fall
in love
and you meet somebody and you're just
empowered by that magic
moment and i draw this analogy all the
time you just
it's so wonderful and everybody should
fall in love with whoever it's going to
be
but then as time passes things change
and maybe
a year or two later you're thinking
about cheating
okay and you do now you have a decision
to make after you've done that
do you tell the truth to your
significant other or do you keep it a
secret
and here's why i bring it up for
business you're going to get caught
100 percent of the time when you cheat
you're going to get caught because you
didn't tell the truth
your significant other can never look at
you the same
again you've lost 50 percent of the
equity in that relationship forever it
may not break up
you may go on but it will never forever
be the same
yeah and in business the first time you
lie to your customers your
constituencies your shareholders
you lose 50 of the equity forever better
to tell the truth and take the hit
and the ownership and transparency and
intent around the i'm sorry
the the that's such that's absolutely
right everything out of your mouth comma
there's also the half pregnant sorry
and there's the real sorry and i think
corporations
the standards in which people want from
companies is completely
completely impossible for most companies
they may be good at
the environment but they're bad at wages
they may like companies are
a convoluted animal just like people and
this
thought that you don't understand how to
say sorry when you're
trying to fix something people would
rather dance
look over there a bird instead of owning
it and to your point
in that lack of apology creates more
damage sometimes than even the event
itself
yes and that's exactly it and i tell all
my ceos now
look do not lie to the customers don't
lie to your employees don't lie to me
don't lie to anybody your shareholders
even take the pain
take the hit admit the mistake you made
and you will build a relationship
particularly with customers
what we're learning online is if you
have a direct relationship with a
customer and you're honest with them
and you tell them hey the product's
going to be delayed or sorry you got a
bad product we'll replace it we'll give
you your money back whatever it is
that communication ends up being very
very valuable over time
those customers stay loyal we've learned
that a hundred fold in our companies now
and now we're in across the portfolio
we're now at 48
directive revenue to customer that's
magic gary
that's friggin magic that cause that's
100 gross margin business
one of the uh we've run out of time
we're gonna move on
we really appreciate your time but one
of the fun topics in the chess game of
what you're talking about is channel
conflict
for the people that still rely on a lot
of business from retail
as retail is watching them go around
them and that is going to be interesting
battles of the next decade of business
let's talk about that next time my
friend thank you so much take care kevin
bye-bye
thanks kevin next up we've got jim
stengel jim was previously the beloved
global cmo of
he's now an industry icon ceo of his
own company host of the cmo podcast
author and speaker
and friend welcome jim thank you andrea
good to see you hi gary hey jim how are
you so for
uh for a minute uh because you're not on
a global television show where i think
everybody knows even though in our
circles
in madison avenue advertising land you
are an absolute legend and a statue but
knowing there's so many different people
here why don't you give a little context
on your career as a marketer and
obviously the kind of
iconic uh role you had and a little bit
about this so i'll give you i'll give
you two minutes to
give a little context because i want the
audience to know who you are sure gary
hey man i'm one of six kids grew up in
lancaster pennsylvania small city grew
up in the city with a bunch of friends
played outside a lot was an entrepreneur
early on
doing whatever i could um you'll love
this gary
i had a thai rental business when i was
in parochial school
i like that so i knocked an old guy's
doors asked if they had some of the old
fat ties from the 40s
i ran them for a dime a day to my
students we started this movement of fat
ties
the monsignor busted me called me a
racketeer
and i was suspended and sent home so
it's all been all been uphill from there
i mean to me you know when i hear that
it's so funny i mean
uh you know we're in a slightly
different age bracket but even for me
when i was growing up
entrepreneurship was completely
demonized school is the only way
there was none of this and when i hear
the fat tie thing knowing the ralph
lauren story i think you were a
creative pioneer my friend well i hope
so anyway i went from there to
journalism
uh went to work with time inc first job
out of college
i saw that the real action was on the
business side
i went to business school full ride penn
state from there to png
png 25 years all over the world last
seven as chief marketing officer got
really fell in love this concept of
brand purpose
having brands aspire to do more than
provide a functional benefit to somehow
change the world
make an impact that's natural for their
history and their category
left the company to start my own firm
all about purpose i wanted to write
about it teach about it help others do
it been doing that for 12 years
investing in companies that are purpose
driven
and now i'm trying to crack this last
area of brand purpose which is how the
hell do we measure it
and find the causality with business
results and we're making great progress
on that
there you are mary two great kids love
my wife
i love that you're you're a great dude
and an inspiration for so many
um in the waters that i swim these days
which is the marketing landscape
jim where where is the customer's
attention and and
and how is that shift in your
perspective knowing that pg
is the iconic television marketer of
that generation
where is the attention when i asked that
question how do you frame that up and
what is your answer
consumers are looking to leaders and
companies
to make a difference right now whatever
data you look at
trust in government is down
way down not just in our country but in
all countries trust in
business and marketing is up
so it's our time and there isn't one
marketing leader right now in one
company that isn't trying to embrace
social action social justice
responsibility
making a difference in people's lives
you know being of service
let me ask you let me ask you a tough
question what percentage of these
companies that are trying to do good
do you feel are completely full of [ __ ]
and are just trying to check the box of
the moment and how many of them
by percentage your gut and how many of
them
are um um actually living it
it's 80 20 living it now let me ask you
a tougher question
because i i have some context of this
what
i i i like that answer but i'm going to
ask you a tougher question
there are cmos that you interact with
and ceos and board members as humans
that i think are giving you the answer
of such a beautiful answer of 80 20
which is a remarkable answer
how many you know when i think of your
answer it makes sense to me because i
think that's
when i think about all the cmos and ceos
that you and i know
as human beings that it's 8 out of 10.
but a lot of those human beings are
looking for their companies to be the
activists on their behalf that's what
they feel
yeah how many of those companies are
actually going to be able to act once
that person actually tries to get the
operation
to do it in a world of publicly traded
board members
other constituents and and competing
agendas how does that manifest in real
life against the intent of those
smalling yeah gary it's a journey but i
can tell you the consumer is seeing a
change
and you know we used to say a png they
still say the consumer is the boss
and and the consumer is expecting
companies
brands leaders to stand for something to
have a voice and to do it
and to do it in action jim why why if
the consumers
of the voice actually now
i'm sorry andrew i'm going off script
because i've got the guy in front of me
why
in a world where somebody like png for
example and others
says the consumers is uh his
boss why are all the reports
internal mmms nielsen's millard brown
the entire currency
awards can the articles adage why is
everything in madison avenue fortune 500
land that reports
actually have very dirty data to the
reality of the consumer
why is there why is there such a big
ecosystem of fake reporting
in marketing land how did that happen
because i sit in meetings constantly
where the brand lift studies and
everything's remarkable you know this
this is what i came into and i'm like
what is this bizarro world
impressions and pr but but it got a can
lion but the businesses
nothing about corporate america fortune
500 marketing
cpg life has been about the actual
customer even though everyone says it
all the currency
is non-consumer-centric yeah gary
you know the great companies have
empathy
they stay close to people they get out
with their teams they're in the field
uh you know people will see through all
this [ __ ]
it's about action and we've been the
research industry has been backward
looking
and not looking at behavior not looking
at causality
with actions and results and that's
where we need to move the research
field that's what i'm working on we've
invested in a startup was a really
promising
methodology to look at purpose
activation and business results the
causality so we're looking at the action
and not what people are saying do you
think fortune 500 brands since that is
such a
strength of yours are contemporary
consumer-centric communicators
where the attention is do you think the
coca-colas the proctors the crafts the
bmws the mercedes i can go on and on and
on starbucks yeah
are they great at knowing where the
customer's attention is and are they
great
at putting creative in front of them or
did they lose their way once it went
away from a traditional television
structure i think they you know many of
them foundered lost their way
didn't you know all the stuff that they
were trained in and were good at kind of
became irrelevant
but i can tell you a silver lining to
this crisis gary is people are renewing
and rebooting
you know the podcast that i do with you
and your team you know i've been talking
to leaders
twice a week different leaders of the
great brands of the world
what the hell is going on how are you
changing how are your teams changing
people are going through a massive
renewal and reboot
and the words i'm hearing are focus
passion empathy humanity agility
more communication social action
that's massively positive and they're
not just this is real
i love it real this is this is not this
is not a veneer this is real
they do they're saying with great
resolve and great action and great
commitments
by and large outside of the altruism and
the positioning and i love this
just curious because i know the kind of
audience we have there's a lot of
conversation in startup land and
entrepreneur land of like hey gary
stop teaching the big companies how to
spend money on facebook and twitter and
instagram because
the costs are going up yeah
your personal do you believe the
creative industry respects the creative
that goes in those channels
or do you think that it's still above
the line below the line that most brands
don't understand
that brand is being built here they
still kind of look at it as like
you know dr down there but brand is done
over here like
do you see cracks in that foundation or
or do you still think like
paying two million dollars for a
production for a tbc still feels right
for my rice ceroni brand or
michelin tires or he's starting to see
that people understand the real crap
like where
where's your pulse on that yeah the
crack the cracks are in the foundation
people are starting to move
you know there's this whole movement i
hate to use another buzzword but people
are looking at the experience of their
brand with people and when you're
starting to think about okay how do
people experience my brand
and you start looking at that thinking
about that measuring that that's not a
tv
ad right that's not a campaign that's
what's happening to the brand and the
person
daily on an interaction are is it
frictionless is it happy is it
delightful
do they exceed expectations so this
whole movement toward looking at
experience is a positive thing
so there are cracks in the foundation of
above and below the line but it's still
it's a massive icon right
all the kids that want to get into
advertising and the last second i got
you here yeah
what should be their modern thought of
approaching that
be creative be consumer-centric be bold
stand out don't be afraid we need those
ideas
art school or post content on social
media or a cold email jim stengel like
what are some of the hacks i would look
for non-traditional
right art school design school uh just
people who are who are ideas based
and do look for ideas to solve problems
that's what a great agency's always done
it's what you guys do
jim it's a real pleasure thank you for
these things gary take care good to be
with you
thanks jim our next guest is charlemagne
the god
author radio and tv personality he's the
outspoken co-host
of the breakfast club a national radio
show
leader of iheart's black effect podcast
network
and just inked a deal with audible
welcome char
yo what's up brother what's up fam
listen
there are very few people that i feel
innovate and do [ __ ] as much as i do
your last nine months i feel like every
time i open my phone
you're announcing some new biz dev some
new production
some new initiative you know
your your capacity to create
opportunities in the last year have been
remarkable you know i've been quietly
sending you messages
because i'm impressed because it's rare
to see i live it
i mean it feels like you have a new
thing every 60 days
kudos on that and that leads me to the
question
is that you reacting to where you see
the consumer attention
is these days forget about what you fill
it with whether it's
selfish selfless you have a lot of
thoughts going through your mind a lot
of agendas a lot of things you want to
see
both for yourself and the world but
before we even get into those things
are you in a place like you're watching
you move right now as a personal brand
i feel like you're reacting to the
understanding of the different shifts of
where people consume
can you speak to that yeah you know
what's so interesting about that gary
um like a lot of the things that people
are seeing
me announce now like those seeds were
planted
two years ago a year and a half ago it's
just that
i guess now with god's divine timing you
know these things are happening now
so it seems like it's a reaction but i
saw this
two years ago i saw where the audio
business was going i saw where
the podcast network business was going
and i always was thinking okay
once we establish a podcast network
which i was already
doing with loudspeakers because i was a
part owner of a loudspeaker but
i wanted to do my own entity but once we
did that
i was thinking to myself okay what's the
next level of audio the next level of
audio to me was scripted
the people are riding in their cars and
the same way they listen to us have
conversations
man why can't we do sitcoms why can't we
do documentaries why can't we do films
and i started seeing like
and charlemagne you know what's crazy
about that technology
brings us to the past some of the shows
that were the biggest hits on tv
started as radio shows people sat around
the radio and listening
all the worlds war of the worlds by
orson welles i always said that i'm like
yo and i i said that with social media i
said it's only a matter of time of some
what
some horse and wealth world stuff
happens because of social media and i
was like
yo why don't i just create the next
horse and well the world type stuff
and by the way giblet giblets showed it
right you know if you think about
podcasts few years ago there were people
whether it was a murder this or murder
that like people started listening
to the soap operas and the interviews
and the things that nature
ctg explain to me your own behavior as a
human
have you adopted tick tock during this
time because attention went there
are you using instagram more do you
watch more lives do you listen to more
podcasts
is it more youtube did you add to
netflix and now you have
disney plus and hbo max like you the
human
your conception your your attention what
has gotten
more of your attention over the last
nine months i mean definitely content
has gotten more of my attention but i
can't
i can't react to what everybody is doing
like i'm not and i i see the hyperbolic
top but i'm not a tic-tock person so i
don't even
go on tick-tock i might see something if
somebody sends it can i ask you a real
can i ask you a real question because
it's important because i know how
thoughtful you are and you know
we've jammed on this for years do you
think there's any part of you
that doesn't go on tick-tock as like the
move
to just not go on tick-tock for the sake
of not going on tick-tock
do you think there's any percentage of
your personality that does that or do
you actually just not think the
attention is worthwhile there
yeah it's just now it's not worth my my
attention you know what i'm saying like
we don't we only have much so much
bandwidth for everything
you know do you do you do you create for
it though
knowing that i mean to me there's less
than 500 people on earth that i would
think of more that can get more value
out of tick tock than you the human
given the cross section of culture and
music it's one thing for you to be in
feed for an hour
watching stuff are you creating for it
and if you're not
why i'm creating for it unintentionally
because people send me stuff all the
time with
them dubbing my voice you know dubbing
an interview from the breakfast club
so whether i'm doing it intentionally or
not i'm creating content for it but me
personally
i don't i don't want i don't want to be
on it why
because i think when i look at what
you're doing on instagram and i think
through what you could be doing on tick
tock right now
i think the things you're passionate
about whether it's racism in america
whether it's awareness to the stuff
you're doing
whether it's just silly jokes whether
it's food whatever the hell you care
about your
opportunity given the attention graph on
tick tock is greater on tick tock
than on instagram though you're spending
your time on instagram
maybe i need to talk to you about it i
just don't see the equity in it for me
now to be honest
let me let me see let we we i'm not
going to take more time here
i'll text you after this the equity is
there's more [ __ ] attention on it
than there is on instagram
wow okay yeah talk to me real quick just
for my own
fun the attention because i know you
also play in this world and you'll be
the only one that can really deliver
during this seminar on that where's the
attention of the music lover today
whether platform whether artist ctg's
hot take on the attention of the music
lover right now
platform or person or anything i'm not
thinking of
i would say it's the streaming services
but i think it's youtube you know when
you look at like
nba young boy your little baby and all
those guys like that like
their youtube numbers are crazy i think
crazy these these kids
they like the visual that goes along
with the music i'm not saying that
they're not screaming music because of
course they are
but i think when you can go on youtube
and actually see
a very creative video by the baby or see
what you know little baby
nba young boy is wearing or who they're
hanging around what car they're driving
that just makes the experience even even
even bigger that's why i like when i go
on
title i love the fact that title has you
know the video component to it
you know that's that's usually what i do
like i i watch
i still watch videos like i did
back in the day you know only because i
know that i can go check them out on
youtube but check them out on title it
was a period of my life where i wasn't
watching no music videos because
it didn't seem like there was a place to
consume but yeah i mean they went up
they basically went away
and now we're kind of back to the heyday
of mtv
because because people are taking
they're taking their visuals
like i gotta give the baby a lot of
credit for that you know what i mean
like the baby really started taking this
visual seriously
and i think a lot of people started
following suit
what about what about in podcast land
you know
what is the attention graph there
whether platform wise
or show wise anything catching your
attention there
um yeah man it's so much you know i mean
shameless plug like i have a lot of
podcasts on my network the black effect
from a lot of talent that you know i
partnered with who's really amazing like
somebody like ebony k williams she has a
podcast called holding court
but she's just breaking down legal cases
and i think that's just something that's
very very educational
it's education it's how a lot of us
learned that weren't great at school
we're learning on the internet
and something like that show which i'm
aware of somebody literally hit me up
about of like
i've literally learning law through this
yeah
and that's that's that's that's what
she's there for somebody like kevin
figaro
you know she's a political pundit but
she just breaks down politics from a
real street level like a like a
like you know she's from l.a so she hung
out with a lot of the gang members and
things like that so she really
understands what's happening on the
concrete
but she also understands what's
happening in you know on capitol hill
and so it's just like those podcasts i'm
learning so much from and even though
they're on the black effect
podcast network the reason i wanted to
partner with talent like that is because
they have those kind of voices
yeah it's a stuff it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy right you wanted to learn from
them
you're scratching your own itch thus
you're trying to get them on your
platform
yeah i mean other than that it's like
people like you know joe rogan i still
love joe rogan
you know i think you know you get so
much out of him you know i mean
i'm a podcast junkie like i listen to so
much podcast a week man it's ridiculous
when do you listen to podcasts working
out um
traveling uh like you sit like in the
middle of the day four to five p.m like
is it in the background at all times how
do you actually consume it
both because you know we i'm i'm
commuting so you know on the way to work
it's a 40-minute commute in the morning
so i'm listening to the podcast on the
way back
it could be up to an hour and a half
just trying to get out of new york you
know when i'm working out that's another
you know hour and a half that i'm
spending spending you know just just
vibing
so like i'm literally listening to
podcasts all the time
like every day i'm listening to a new
podcast charlemagne i wish you nothing
but health i'll hit you up about tick
tock
and i'll see you soon thank you you got
it bro
stay well next we welcome gia hyun
vp head of north america marketing
solutions for linkedin
known as a marketing vet that drives
growth
gia has worked at linkedin ge capital
citigroup american express and
mastercard
she's also an enthusiastic amateur
pickle
artisan and loves dancing welcome gia
gia if i had more time than 10 minutes
i'd be talking only about pickling
because i find that amazing um you uh
first of all how are you
um and when you were posed with the
question
where is the consumer's attention right
now how do you consume that
and how do you articulate it thank you
for being here yeah
first of all thank you so much for
having me and we can definitely do a
full episode just on the art of
fermentation
um it's a must right now i think you and
i are
destined to do a wine and pickle pairing
show
i would love that yes yes um i mean i
i'm doing well we are we are doing well
the business is
actually doing really well the platform
has
is is explosive in terms of both the
volume of conversation that's happening
on linkedin but also the
type and the the types and the breadth
of conversations happening on linkedin
yeah i mean it has been changing for
years now
i've been at linkedin for five years and
when i first joined
you know it was there was a common
understanding
or i would call misunderstanding about
linkedin that it's
just a job site or it's just a
professional networking site or it was
just a place for
people to do b2b marketing in a very
very niche way
and certainly jobs is an important part
of the conversations that are happening
on linkedin right now there are a lot of
people looking for jobs there are a lot
of companies that are looking to hire
there are a lot of people looking to up
skill
and and really improve the trajectory of
their careers during this time
and so that's still a really important
part of what
the conversation the dialogues that are
happening on linkedin are
and you know there are 700 million plus
members on linkedin that are leaning
into that particular part of the
experience
and if you check out hashtag
offeringhelp
open to work i encourage you to lean in
and give and get help in that capacity
but that's just the very sort of obvious
tip
of the whole iceberg because you know
when we talk about where the attention
is going
you know we've known for a while
internally at linkedin that
every professional is a consumer every
professional
is a person who has their personal
circumstances
you know and and linkedin has always
been a place where conversations between
businesses and professionals happen
every day and some of it's about
business solutions of course it's about
jobs but it's about personal development
it's about what i need in my life to be
successful tomorrow today
what i need in my life there are
solutions that are going to make my life
more productive
and easier and you know
i apologize for interrupting because i'm
just thinking about the constituents
that are watching the show and how to
extract value
what you know let me ask you a couple
questions because i you know i'm not
sure if this is on your radar but i've
been screaming about linkedin's value
for about
last three years from an organic nature
and really from a media targeting nature
if you're in the b2b space
are are people would people be shocked
if they sell
soap if they sell workout
you know programs if they sell hoodies
it you know
if they you know do you think do you
think
i want to dig back into that because i
want to bring value is it conversation
within linkedin
i mean i don't i don't want to say it
this way but like it's almost to me the
facebook
vacation of linkedin which is the
broadness even when you were saying it i
kind of made this gesture
i am blown away by how much wine you
know linkedin started as a utility
you know his job life it is now a
full-blown content
ecosystem and yes you might you you must
factor in the psychology
of a linkedin user when they're in a
linkedin feed which will be different
than
that same person being on tick tock but
the breadth of what you can do on the
platform
for me today feels i look at it the same
way i look at
facebook or twitter is that
so are you seeing that is that being
talked about
absolutely 100 agree with you but i will
i will challenge you a little bit
in terms of sort of dividing line
between what's b to c
and b to b is not the way we're
necessarily looking at it because it's
really about
business to professional right in an
advertisement
right for example i apologize
when you can target by job title
in a way that you can't anywhere else my
ability
if i'm selling a sas product to target
by people who hold the title as chief
innovation officer
right and then create content for that
creates a unbelievable
framework for b2b marketing that is
different
than i can do on than on facebook or
tick tock
so i can go broad on linkedin on
consumer but you have a substantial
advantage in b2b marketing over the
competitive landscape because of your
targeting capabilities
yeah i mean the targeting absolutely the
context
absolutely the mindset people bring to
the platform absolutely
those are big things those are big
things and if you think about the
conversations that used to happen that
were sort of the provenance of
boardrooms and the prominence of
conference rooms that everyone thought
was very different and distinct from
conversations that happened
at the water cooler or the cafeteria or
in the hallways or during the commute
especially in the past year those walls
came
down because literally all of those
conversations are happening with the
same people
in one room in most instances it's your
kitchen table it's your office
i'm in my apartment right now doing
business yeah
real quick i apologize uh khalifa y who
says yeah but the cpcs are too high
the the reality is that's a creative
game the reason so many people struggle
on linkedin or any other platform for
that matter on their cpcs
because the cpa you know cpas are higher
you know the cpms are higher when you
get better targeting is the creative
more so than the targeting do you think
people have really struggled
in a world where data and information
have advanced
in understanding that creative's still
the variable like i can get in front of
that cfo
on linkedin but if my picture video and
information isn't good
nobody's buying anything there's a
trillion gary v wannabes out there
there the variable of the creative is
the important part
thoughts on that yeah i mean kevin
touched upon
this uh jim talked about it a little bit
in terms of there's sort of shortcuts
that we take in terms of measurement
that
that are supposed to be proxies for
something the cpc is not
a proxy for quality cpc is not a proxy
for the stickiness of the engagement
or or the value or the resonance of the
message that you've landed with the
consumer and so
i challenge the notion that you know i
think that on cpc
alone you're not going to know that
you're creating resonance you're not
going to know that you're making an
impact on that consumer
i think that's good it's always common
for quality
yeah i'm sure i'm sorry one more time
it's going to be quality over quantity
quantity is going to be important and
who doesn't love scale
but but you know what scale without
impact
gia what what about your own personal
attention behaviors
have you expanded your ott line up at
home
you know maybe there's some good
pickling somewhere
while the fermentation is happening in
the basement i've got
i i'm probably over subscribed on the
streaming side and then
i think where i'm active is linkedin
where i'm active is instagram and then
um i've got i've got i've got my tick
tock feet going and with my uh
peripheral visions i gotta watch my kids
and
uh and then twitter i'm i'm passively
and actively consuming
so it's kind of all happening in tandem
but
you know i i think the thing that just
going back to
you know as these walls are coming down
in terms of what is appropriate or what
was really uniquely suited to
this particular environment versus the
other uh
because we're seeing this incredible
convergence happening on our platform
you know we're we're super excited about
launching stories where you know stories
is not a new format
it's it's a format that everyone's
familiar with in other platforms
but this idea that we kind of all miss
those moments in the office if you will
where you said hey check this out look
what's happening right now
look look what i'm doing right now look
what i just learned
that kind of thing that that we're able
to do on linkedin
through the stories format is really
exciting particularly in this particular
point in time
and then you know live in events i mean
we're doing
this live stream live streaming on
linkedin right now
it's an incredibly exciting development
because here again we're bringing down
the walls i mean there there was there
was a time where
participating in a conversation like
this and having
a front row seat to a conversation like
this uh
required you to travel required you to
find room capacity and require it i mean
there was so much logistics involved and
some events were just not accessible to
everybody so
having live um as a feature on the
platform and then
the ability to bring a bunch of events
functionality around that where we can
get
individuals and businesses the ability
to
bring people in in invite them
showcase the content live and then be it
you know and then
given the ability to actually have pull
through on that
after the live event that's something
that i think is very now
very relevant and so important to you
know making this conversation accessible
to everybody
gee i really appreciate your time
continued success thanks for being on
thank you so much thanks gia
next up kavita gupta co-founder of
fintech tv
and delta growth fund she's at stanford
university where she teaches beyond
bitcoin and ethics for ai after leading
a vc hedge fund
investing in block blockchain technology
and kavita received the un social
finance
innovator award for her work on the
green bond team
at the world bank welcome kavita
thank you peter how are you good
was that a very nerdy introduction to
start with
like i always say whether it's a good or
bad introduction or nerdy or funny or
silly
even getting an introduction is pretty
nice isn't it
true true absolutely how are you doing
today um well
i think the concept of the show um where
is the consumer's attention
i'd love to get uh your perspective and
thoughtful mind on that when you hear
that where does your mind go and
and where do you take that conversation
for me the my mind goes on privacy
like we are talking today is the time
when everybody's talking about data
privacy what's happening to our data
uh where are we going with whether it's
the ads whether it's
using anything on internet and it could
be in financial sector it could be
related to my credit card it could be
related to uh
my presence or like whatever i go on my
search
and it is so funny every time i have
this conversation even when i teach and
i
ask students um we have all the problems
but when you think of one product or one
company which
is providing your solution across those
stream which one do you think of
i do sometimes hear apple here and there
but nothing on financial space nothing
in
other search space people are like yeah
these are our issues we don't have a
solution
that's where we're living right now what
do you think the issue
what do you think most people think when
you think about privacy as an attention
conversation
i i am blown away by people's inability
to describe what they're upset about
right um i mean i think this is very
important right
i mean like when i'm i go into very
thoughtful you know
i understand why it's a conversation for
the intellect
i understand why it's happening at
universities and media
companies and i understand the
conversation i
i'm fascinated by the collective human
being's
inability to say what's upsetting them
because they'll speak to well i don't
like the algorithm controlling me and
when you ask them a second question
they're unable to continue the
conversation
what what is your perspective on that i
think it's very individual right now
because we don't have regulation so we
don't have a common platform for people
to come together and say this is 16
points but these are 15 points if you go
to africa
most of the people are like can we even
say whatever we want to say on twitter
or facebook and not go to jail for them
privacy just fall down upon that right
when you come to us and people like
again you said it very clearly like
there is a classes and classic and stuff
like
class and a mass right so when you go
into the class society
you you are talking about very
intellectual things oh i want
my financial details nobody should have
my driving license number why do they
need my height
and my age and all this stuff on my deal
and then take photocopies every time i
check in the hotel
versus if you go to a teenager going to
college
they would be more interested about hey
if i have to delete something on my
twitter facebook or anywhere on my
social media from my young days to when
i'm getting a job
where is my privacy between this and
what can a person
hiring me can see and cannot see so it
really depends it's a very individual
approach from going to jail all the way
to my drunken pictures that
when i was 15 years old so there is no
common platform for it so far
and do you and do you think there should
be i think there should be
because a financial privacy is very
different than an identity privacy
versus
uh your social versus private life
privacy you know the new generation
which is like
my my nieces and like my very young
nieces who are coming in it
they don't understand whatever they are
posting what is going to be the
repetition
of those things and how it can be used
or abused against them because right now
we are all just figuring it out and by
the time we figure out
it may or may not be late you know and
and give me a worst-case scenario of
used and abused against someone from the
way that you filter the conversation
um a lot of times like uh i i mean look
at our politicians right the younger and
like look at aoc
like you know there was like literally
was posted her dance moves from her
college days
and you're still talking about this
generation i mean the way she handled it
was really really great kudos to her
but it was used against oh she is not
responsible enough to
take care of you with all her belief
systems and everything even after 10
years or 12 years
but how how is that different than when
people showed a picture of gary hart
with his potential mistress and the
enquirer in 1988
or or the you know the way that richard
nixon
you know with all his things he had to
go through like
what is the difference in that scenario
because i understand the information
but you know joe joe biden making a
quote or donald trump not sharing his
taxes like
the distribute you're talking about the
distribution mechanism but that behavior
around people has always existed no
so there was much more difficult for
having a proof with respect to footage
video you have to have investigative
journalists you have to find your target
you have to go behind them they have to
be a certain level
whatever happened at watergate you have
a sitting president and you went against
it or
in case of clinton or something you had
the whole commission going
now all you have to do is to hire
somebody and just scrub your google
history
but wouldn't that speak to a more
transparent world because in the past it
was subjective
and people with high wealth were able to
make deals with the people that own the
media companies and thus
so much never came out one could argue
that this becomes far more transparent
the world that you're describing
led to people that had political clout
with walter mondale or with rupert
murdoch
and they were actually able to suppress
information at a much higher
level and then it was just selective
exposure versus the framework we're in
now
i think those are two there's a
decentralization part which should
absolutely be there for transparency but
then there is a part where you choose
where you are aware
about what you put out by yourself
is your own responsibility how many
youngsters know whatever they are
putting out on instagram on snapchat
is completely just out there and about
for the rest of their existence or even
after that i think that
thought about this knowledge that
education
the part missing sorry go ahead no i'm
sorry uh the question there though is
doesn't society then move along with it
right you know i'd love to understand
this notion
that you taking a photo with you know
doing beer pong
or all these things that these children
don't know what they're doing
i'm asking individuals to give me the
actual story of ramifications
this notion of nieces are out of control
and then they have
actual real life ramifications has been
a
has been the toughest part of this
conversation in my opinion
you know people speak about it
theoretically but then society's norms
move along with it
because underneath the the empathy and
hypocrisy frameworks that are built
around more exposure
follow alongsuit you know i please
i i i agree with you and i think it is a
combination of that awareness
plus it's a combination of having rules
that you know certain things cannot be
used for your professional and unless
it's directly related to it
if you have abused a woman or a man or
an individual growing up then
any proof social media or not social
media should be used
but if it is about you and your
individual space that your friend's
house was drinking
legally that should not be used for
banning you not to do a particular job
you know so i think but but i don't
think it is
i think i don't think anybody who drank
underage has been eliminated from
politics as a matter of fact
i would argue that what this world has
allowed is
everyone's actually in play for politics
because what happens is the reverse
and then the other bigger question comes
in the way that you're framing it up
where is the responsibility of
self-responsibility or parenting
we have an entire generation of parents
who want to blame technology
for their shortcomings of creating a
framework for their children
that could be interesting and absolutely
not
my deep understanding or like i'm not an
expert of it
but i do believe that's a very
interesting topic and then technology
which should go
so like on our platform at fintech.tv we
do like deep thought
thought leadership 30 minutes 20 minutes
interviews across blockchain and past
stories and everything
and how technology impact is coming out
on next generation whether
it is in in a positive way which is
environment sustainability or blockchain
or something
versus the negative way i think those
conversations would be very important
you just gave me an idea to do a new
series about it
well i'm glad any final thoughts on this
since i see i have one more minute
anything we didn't get to touch on
because i know these go fast and i
really appreciate your time
no yeah yeah it's great i think uh my
final thoughts would be
i think i would say all the marketers
out there who are
working with amazing products that your
billion
uh that your billions citizens whom you
want to put next
is actually outside us outside europe
look into the international market look
into the technologies of blockchain
which provides you transparency
cryptocurrencies which are providing you
the same day settlements for an amazing
business to go in a trillion dollar
market outside the country
is what have always worked in and where
i feel is the space
and uh we even us when we are doing
all these stuff on fintech.tv we
realized that regulations and everything
which we are
building up in u.s are actually much
more
apt to everything that we are doing in
emerging markets who are ahead
who are way ahead of us in what's
happening in u.s so
my last thought would be just go and
check out the emerging markets
thank you thanks for being on andrea
thanks
next up we have raja rajamanar the chief
marketing and communications
officer and president of healthcare for
mastercard
raja is an accomplished global business
executive with more than 25 years of
experience
including a long list of industry awards
including global marketer of the year
and most tech savvy cmo and
coming soon you must read his first book
quantum marketing
welcome raja thank you very much sandy i
really appreciate it
raj a very important question right off
the bat first of all it's great to see
you and i hope you're well
did you actually read all those books
behind you yes i did
i'm impressed thank you i i had a
feeling i had a feeling
50 books every year absolutely good for
you
is that the majority of your consumption
if you're doing 50 books a year
obviously either you're a very prolific
reader or have the skill set of
competing comprehension
or do books actually take a high
percentage of your
consumption behavior versus let's say
the phone or the television or
or audio and podcast it's
one of those traditional readers who
like to read physical books
and that's what i spend a lot of my time
on good for you
what's the last actually just for fun
and bring value what's the last great
book that really caught your attention
recently
it was the revision of uh the book by
sean eckhart the happiness advantage
very cool and what's the what's the
macro thesis there for anybody who's
interested
you know it's very philosophical in one
sense and highly pragmatic
had another you know the whole premise
is normally people
will work hard to accomplish success
and once they get success they buy a
whole bunch of things for themselves
and then they are all happy the reality
is just the opposite when you are in a
happy state of frame
you work much better and you achieve
more success
and it's a beautiful reframing and
something which might be blindingly
obvious to some
but not too many so i think it's a
fascinating book from that perspective i
love it
the theme of the show where is the
consumer attention
you know obviously mastercard clearly
sits on enormous amounts of data which
gives it advantages over many other
companies in the world so you may have
an interesting perspective on this
just from your perspective when you hear
that question
how does it filter your mind and and
where do you go with that answer
so two things one is in terms of where
their mind is and second is where their
behavior is manifested
so we measure the behavior uh through
something called spend a spending pulse
we see the transactions of how people
are spending on different categories
and we also do tracking more in terms of
the psychology of consumers
so i'll ignore the most obvious one like
elections everyone is preoccupied with
election services to the u.s right now
but the things which are fascinating to
me of what people are really preoccupied
with
is redefining their entire lives
recrafting and redesigning their lives
because everything has been put
topsy-turvy
the kids are staying at home there is no
school you can't go to office and you
are
you know having social distance you
cannot meet friends and you're getting
obsessed and
literally addicted to various digital
devices they are completely re-examining
this
big time in their own way consciously
subconsciously whatever
second and heightened uh focus on
well-being
it's not just health as in physical
health and mental health but overall
well-being which includes it's more a
mental state to say
financially i'm all right my kids are
doing well my job is secure or whatever
it is
so it's a whole package we call it
well-being in total
the third one i would say is an amazing
jump in adoption of pets
yes it's it's extraordinary how much of
you know
uh a movement we see in that
entertainment very obvious because you
don't have anything else to do you are
looking at entertainment streaming and
all that good stuff
uh fortunately for us shopping is still
continuing very strong
and you'll be surprised to see that the
shopping levels
uh other than travel have already
crossed
the pre-covet levels last year yeah
there's an enormous amount of money
spent on travel and then
restaurant and alcohol on premise and so
those dollars and with stimulus checks
and with wall street not feeling the
effects
outside of pockets of main street people
have
more money and need to spend it now
what i'm worried about is what happens
when the other shoe fits when we get
back to real life
because there's some real ramifications
absolutely and in fact that's where the
big thing is
uh it does look like i know even if the
recession is going to continue for a
while
uh consumer confidence has not gone down
in terms of the ability to spend on
things that they think are essentially
today whether it is home improvement
or food or online those things are not
going to really drop
and in the mass affluent and the
affluent segments
the luxury spending is actually coming
right back up
so the indulgence is all there and not
depending on the segment that you're
talking at the geography that you're
talking about
uh like kavita was mentioning before
there's a heightened
awareness and concern for safety and
security which is
occupying people it's not just cyber
security but also an anticipation of
social
unrest i apologize for interrupting
because i want to get this question in
as i came across and i'm reading
comments
do credit card companies have a
vulnerability with youth behavior
around apps and blockchain and things of
that nature
or having in the macro has the industry
is the industry positioned well it seems
to be a very
interesting debate around that just
curious from your perspective
yeah so in fact uh you know if you look
at blockchains and
areas like that they are more
a form of a transaction or an enablement
of transaction
so for example you might be surprised
that if you look at the top five
patent filing companies on blockchains
mastercard will be one of those
right so we actually embrace and try to
use the new technologies and new
enablements
to keep driving and enabling consumers
to be able to spend in a convenient safe
secure manner
so it doesn't adversely impact us and if
at all anything if they are spending
more time on apps and making in-app
purchases
online purchases it's increasing that's
really better for us right
what about relevance for the youth like
how do you self-assess your company like
how relevant is mastercard the brand to
let's say
15 to 25 from your perspective so in
fact what i would say is
as a brand we have largely been seen as
an ingredient brand
it's not a direct to consumer end
consumer brand that's how it has been
but from that stage we are making a very
nice movement and depending on the
country in some countries we are seen as
one of the top five aspirational brands
for the youth
so they look at it as a cool brand now
for example if you are sponsoring
uh you know uh we have got about 100
dance music festivals electronic dance
music festivals we are in esports
so it's all about what they see the
context in which your brand is appearing
and then the association keeps forming
so you find in many countries actually
mastercard does very well for their
young population particularly they may
not be eligible for by getting a credit
card or a debit card or whatever be the
card
but they have got the brand awareness
they got the right perceptions about the
brand
and they think that it is not a stayed
old brand of my father or grandfather
but it's a brand which is contemporary
and part of our rebranding exercise
to take away our name mastercard from
our logo it's just a pure symbol brand
that we have got
we got the sonic brand we are heavily
into music into movies and into arts and
culture
uh esports all these things was
essentially to build our equity amongst
these segments
which has been pretty positive in terms
of outcomes for us i love that
the last couple minutes we have here
your guess
slash most thoughtful response to
what's the biggest shift in attention
in a normalized post-covered world
there'll be a new reality
of sorts when i say that what's your
anticipation where some of the actual
attention
ears and eyes of the end consumer where
will they have aggressively shifted to
more that was accelerated by this one
two year event
that will be looked back on by every
person
on earth today it's a combination of
three things
it's a digitization of everything
everything becoming remote
everything becoming contactless
very concise my friend these are the
three i'll give you back a minute
because i know you have another book to
read
thank you very much talk to you soon
bye-bye bye-bye
thank you raja next up we have lori abu
habib
senior vice president and chief
marketing officer of sonic drive-in
a 13-year vet of sonic lori joined the
company as a product pipeline manager
she was named sonic corporation's
employee of the year
among many many other awards welcome
lori
hey thanks so much i'm super excited to
be here good to see you
great to see you lauren have you been
doing this i mean i see over your right
shoulder
uh a very very very cute picture so i
think we have to give that a shout out
first
but how have you been and and and how
are you getting through all this
yeah you know i've been great i actually
have i had a covet baby
so um had a baby in june uh it's been
quite the experience but
um you know there's certainly pros and
cons of this entire
experience i think being able to spend
time with family as so many of
consumers are doing um you know i'll
take that as a win especially with the
little one at home
i love that um so lori the framework of
this conversation obviously it's a blitz
of 10 minutes
where is consumer attention what have
you seen from your purview
both as a marketer on top of one of the
iconic and
and super strong qsr companies in our
country but then maybe even as you as a
well-rounded marketer we've had the
luxury of speaking in the past i've
always thought you
had really good intuition anytime i was
seeing some progressive stuff i always
liked the way it landed with you
and even your own behavior which how do
you hear that and how do you think about
the future yeah you know it's um it's
been an exciting ride like the last few
months and i think um
the one thing that's really stood out to
me is our country is just really
embracing indulgence
and you know sonic yes brand um we
stride away from that in the past it's
been something that's sort of in the
cornerstone of the dna that we really
didn't fully embrace and as we did some
soul searching you know pre-coven
pre-covered
we really landed on this idea of how
important indulgence is and what a
profound role you know i think it can
really play in consumers lives and so
uh you know we we thought we'd just
embrace it and kind of own who we are
and so that's certainly something that
has been relevant
um definitely to sonic but to me in my
life
laurie is that as simple as hey
a nice milkshake is good and like tater
tots are fun sometimes like let's not be
so
like is it literally as simple as that
at some level i think that's certainly
an aspect of it um i think right now you
know i
100 of believe that tons of people are
just eating their feelings and so
i think it's like yeah getting exactly
what you want but also
you know also having me time having
space to get out of the house
being able to spend your time exactly
how you want it so i think that there's
lots of dimensions on that because
there's just so many new
responsibilities that are sort of
layered on people right now so
there's the escapism but i think that
there's also that
the simplicity of um yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna eat these calories and they're not
gonna count because it's gonna make me
feel better and it's part of my
self-care
right what about um the notion of
how you're thinking about spending
marketing dollars you know where is the
attention of the consumer
you know obviously your brand ranges in
age
demos income levels psychographic
demographic
how are you thinking about modern day
media planning
has the evolution i feel like we've gone
through this year of
there was a whole lot of bad planning
around bad tv and bad digital
and i feel something's brewing with
covid where marketers are becoming
a little bit more practitioners thus
giving them better insights do you see
that to be true
all right when you talk to other cmos or
your crew underneath you parallel to you
around you former teammates what's your
point of view of the state of the
uh union of consumer marketing and where
do you see the attention of the consumer
where
are some of the opportunities and what
are some of the things that you think
have been exposed
because of covid yeah it's a great
question i would say the general
consensus
um with my peers and my team has
certainly been around this idea of you
know
flexibility and how much flexibility can
we get
there's never enough i think at this
point in time to really to your point
make sure that you can
curate your solutions based on the
circumstances as they present themselves
and so
obviously digital provides a ton of
flexibility there
and that's certainly something that uh
was first and foremost in our playbook
is how do we really leverage that um
you know i think we were fortunate from
a sonic perspective to really be well
positioned
to kind of leverage all things digital
in between you know media spins
certainly but then also
our own channel ecosystem which has been
just a tremendous asset um
the last nine months so i think it's
about you know being able to flex
um we've seen trends come across
obviously social because we you know we
talk about that a lot right
but um you know other areas like full
episode player that are really
kind of eroding that more traditional
stance uh that we
we've seen that trend happen over time
but certainly it seems to be
accelerating these days as well so i
think that brought to light a lot of
those pieces that were just naturally
going to happen over time and really
kind of put the put the gas on it
let me throw a couple of things that are
happening in contemporary marketing and
get a sense of your hot take on it what
about
influencer marketing your personal or
professional point of view on that
yeah i think um it can be super
beneficial
if you use it in the right way you know
it's all about context and so making
sure that
you have the right um audience
connective tissue you know where your
consumer is coming from
you're really clear on where that
influencer stance is and it is a really
tight connection
back to the idea that you're trying to
get across i think that
it can work really well i think that
there's certainly instances where you
can overuse it and then it seems like
you know um any sponsorship that's out
there you're taking advantage of so i
yeah i think uh
what more combination in that scenario
what is the danger in your opinion
because there's two sides to that
statement right it's interesting right
if you're taking advantage of every
influence or every popping trend one
could argue that you're
you've got a framework of
contemporariness and that that's what
you're trying to play on
i'm curious your perspective on why that
could be an issue i think it will help a
lot of people who are watching
sure i really you know i think it comes
back to the idea of authenticity
you know and i think that's something
just from a macro level that is a really
big deal to consumers right now they
want to know what you stand for
and if you stand for everything then you
stand for nothing and so
making sure that you really get tight on
the opportunities that you're going to
attach yourselves to
i think really makes a statement about
who you are and where you're going and
what you stand for
lori on that point do you think
consumers though can consume enough
of all those things from a brand to give
them that you know
i i understand that thesis and then i
think a lot is me asking me
a question and you you know this notion
that if you're everything to everybody
you're sponsoring a tick tock dancer
you're sponsoring a comedian you're
sponsoring a 50
you know i get it in theory but do you
think consumer behavior on the other
side of this
conversation is actualized
because running creative on to 60 year
olds on facebook in a certain way
is going to be different than what
you're going to put on tick tock running
that ad spending
the carolinas may be different than what
you run somewhere else
just curio you know i understand in in
hypothesis
in actualization are consumers able to
in the fragmentation of the world
actually even get to a place where i
mean ultimately a very simple question
do you think a consumer will step back
and say
oh man adidas is trying to be everything
to everybody or oh man sonic's trying to
like because i saw six different things
do you think that manifests you know i
think there's a good point that it
probably isn't
um other than like you're really super
fans that would really be exposed to
that sort of consumption
but i do think i think you still have to
be careful you know about curating the
story i think um
making sure that even if you are in
those places in a variety of channels
and showing up in different ways
that it still connects back to that
continuity of
of who you are at the core right and i
think if you you can get distracted by
jumping on trends and you know kind of
throwing your hat in every conversation
and that's where i think the danger is
that
you know maybe it's not a matter of an
individual consumer
getting um you know confused by a
certain message but i do think it's
it's erosion on kind of your your
overall
brand positioning to individual humans
rethink with them
internally from an operational
standpoint well maybe both
um certainly there's an internal risk
but i think i think you uh once you let
the guard rails down like the
the risk to meander is certainly
certainly higher
the during this period for you
personally as a marketer
as an observer or within the
organization however you want to frame
it
the thing that became obvious to you
even more so than ever before back to
the acceleration you refer to as
this is just overpriced activity in 2020
and the thing that became most obvious
to you of this kind of tactic is under
price and i want to be doing more of in
the back row
what what is what's the up down you know
kind of a moment like
super hot more hot on podcasting down on
twitter ads
super fired up about outdoor down on
radio like you know who's the winner and
loser
through laurie's mind as a marketer and
making decisions
as you go forward what what got exposed
and what was
hmm maybe i was underestimating that and
i'm gonna be doing more of that
well i will tell you like out of home is
pretty good example that's
that was an obvious one right um uh but
i think for us really you know we've
been in this sort of digital migration
over time on
obviously big spend in terms of national
tv and cable
and so i don't think it was as much as
like a huge up and down for us
as accelerating a migration that was
kind of already in place and for us it's
moving more towards
um social but also diversifying our
digital channels on making sure that we
have a stronger presence on search
um that our acquisition buys into our
own channels are
in the right places because we're really
paying off so
it was it was less about you know taking
one from one place and adding it
directly to the other and more about
kind of
taking that slow migration of a large
spin in one place
and really diversifying it up to get the
biggest bang for a buck across you know
a variety of different channels
lori thank you so much for your time
congratulations on all the amazing
things at home
in real life and continue the great
marketing hey thanks gary good to see
you
thanks lori next up we're excited to
welcome jason brown
vice president of marketing for champs
sports and east bay
jason began his career over 15 years ago
holding leadership roles at fox sports
nbc sports and pepsico where he earned
the charles
professor x xavier collaboration award
jason is on a mission to inspire and
empower
youth culture welcome jason thanks guys
how are you
jason it's good to see you man you as
well man how are you
i'm well i'm really glad you're on the
show cause i think you'll bring some
really fun uh insights here right off
the bat let's get right into it
where is the consumer's attention how do
you quantify that in your mind and
what's the answer
well i think you heard it just now our
our mission at foot locker
is to inspire and empower youth culture
and given that we're predominantly
focused
on gen z i think what's transpired the
past six
to eight months has really been
exacerbated it exacerbated what we
already know
consumers want brands that align
philosophically with their value
system and they want you to take a stand
somewhere wherever that is and we found
numerous ways to engage and and that
could be
the environment that could be
encouraging civic participation
there's numerous ways in which you can
do that and i think they want to see
that even more
than they did before just given the
volatility that we're experiencing right
now
i think that would definitely be my
biggest takeaway over the past six
months during this covert time period
and and what about from um so that
macro what about in the uh in the
trenches one thing i've always liked
when we've interacted is we've always
talked
into our quick passes and events nba
all-star cs
it always feels like a contemporary
conversation which usually leads to of
the moment
you know so for this one i think will
help so many because we have a
big breadth of entrepreneurs kids
executives board members fortune 500
how important for a brand and a a slew
of companies that you're overseeing
is tick tock right this second like just
right to the punch line like thinking
about your business
how important is that platform it's it's
definitely important and i would say
that we definitely haven't cracked the
code yet
but it's definitely one that rene do you
feel it do you feel like
if when i hear you say that i'm sorry to
jump in but do you feel like
[ __ ] we just really need to win on this
platform pretty soon because the longer
we go
somebody else is gonna take that heat no
absolutely and i think there's there's
also the fine line of making sure that
you're doing it the right way
i mean you think about when people are
just buying followers and just
trying to sponsor anyone they could
without being meaningful
and i know just even to your previous
conversation about influencers that's
something that
we use throughout all social platforms
but one of the things that i i
try to evangelize with my team is
creating partnerships with influencers
not just people to repost something so
we can count impressions at the end of a
recap
you know it has to be meaningful and has
to be purposeful so
when you think about tick tock and what
we're trying to accomplish there
given that tick tock is really
predicated on music and dance
worse we're primarily focused on sports
so how do we bring how do we stay true
to who we are
and then make that relevant to tick tock
and that audience because i mean when
you think about
think about athletes in the end zone
when they score a touchdown
think about the the handshakes that guys
give when they're going into the
basketball court
how do you that's something that's
relevant to tick tock how do you take
that choreography
and apply it to tick-tock in a
meaningful way where it's still true to
us
still true to sports and relevant to
that audience
i think that is an extremely extremely
good point do you think
though in broader terms i think one
thing that people
do in these moments is get a little
narrow when the mass of it is just
underpriced attention
the biggest thing i've learned in the
last 15 years and watching you know
from my spaces come up to where we are
right now on
on tick tock is at times we
overthink things sometimes just the
sheer youth is so there
that it's just a game of like micro to
macro like to me 8 000 x
if i buy your your company tomorrow i'm
like we're doing 18 000 things on that
platform asap
because almost everything's working out
because the underpriced nature of the ad
product
the influencers on it like the whole
thing feels macro underpriced
and i do think at times and i and i've
become educated on why companies have to
think these things through which is just
politics and internal [ __ ] but like
the reality is the net net
is underpriced thoughts on that so i i
do agree with some of those things that
you were just saying but i think what
you got to take into consideration i'll
give you a really good example
please this was the first time in
history where we had to close our entire
fleet of stores during covet right
so then depending upon what was going on
in the states
certain stores were opening before
others and then obviously people also
have
a different level of comfort as it
relates to going into a store even
though we try to follow all guidelines
make people as comfortable as possible
snapchat we worked with them and we were
the first
retail brand to take advantage of the
sneaker ar
augmented reality try on right so back
to school is very different this year
this was back to school like we've never
seen so
you're right i could take all my money
and put it into tick tock and try to
create all this awareness
but why not focus on my back to school
bets the priorities that we're trying to
bring to life
and allow the kid who may or may not be
able to go to the store
who's on snapchat to be able to try on a
shoe
virtually and purchase it so i think
those are the kind of things you got to
take into consideration
you can't just chase the cool kids if
that doesn't necessarily
uh solve for what you're trying to
accomplish and with what snapchat
recently did in terms of that program
and execution
i looked at that as a win jason on that
note because i couldn't agree more with
that last part
and you being at pepsico and i know a
lot about the way that company scores
or at least historically has why
why to your point you basically just
said hey we need to do the thing that
the business needs
why do all the big companies you work
for
score on media metrics not business
results
it's a combination of both those media
metrics definitely are taken into
consideration
but you have to look at media and
isolation in the sense of making sure
that your dollars are working
i agree that it's one of those processes
that could definitely get better and be
a bit more integrated
you know i think i mean let's call a
spade a spade let's educate some kids
here as they're going into the industry
like you know the holding company media
company is incentivized against a
certain cost and
thus that inventory gets chosen or an
internal mm is built
that justifies television spend but
doesn't justify facebook spend
thus nobody spends on facebook in 2013
or 11 when it's the number one platform
on earth i mean there's some there's a
big disconnect you're now in retail
thank god so you're getting clean
returns
information on sales but like cpg land
is a disaster
it's hard it's it's a challenging
business it's a challenging business
especially when you think about the
volume especially on a global level
it's really hard to correlate that
together so i think i was actually
reading an article about uh elon musk
you know and steve jobs i think they
both took the same approach in terms of
making sure that they broke down as many
silos
so that everyone had the same goal right
so if
if i'm in the media department i'm going
to make sure that
there are the impressions the engagement
the roi as relates to media is through
the roof and unfortunately that might
not put me in a position to where i
should be as commercially minded as i
should
and i think as you start to see more
integration at those companies
with more of that common goal you'll see
that benefit
as it relates to both being having a bit
more parody
i think you're very versed in the
current state of the
end of humans what how about you
yourself
jb's personal attention graph
these days what is winning in your world
which show
on ott which artist which
which app what it what what have you and
give me a little storytelling on
something that's evolved like oh i
wasn't into podcasts before kobit
now cause i work out in my home gym i am
or i used to just have netflix but now i
have hulu and
roku and or i downloaded tiktok and i'm
about it now like
what's evolved increased or decreased in
your actual media consumptions
i would say that uh i've definitely
gotten more into audio books
i was always into podcasts i
i guess we could laugh at this one but
um
when quibby launched i did want to see
the clippers documentary so
yes i joined quibby for a week so i
could watch that one
um obviously bad timing in terms of when
and where and how
was it what did you say how was it i
didn't see any feedback on it good
that documentary was great it was you
had to obviously restart it for the
seven episodes that was kind of annoying
but the content itself was great
um but that that's the biggest change as
relates to platforms but i think one of
the things i'd want to focus on is a
moment
and i think one of the best moments we
had especially is me being a sports fan
sneaker fan etc
was what we had with the last dance of
course when you take into consideration
how espn was able to pull that off
and when you think of how appointment
television viewing
does not exist today in in comparison to
how it was in the past unless it is live
sports
i think the way that that galvanized the
country even non-sports fans was amazing
and shows how powerful content
and great storytelling can be jason i
really appreciate your time i wish you
continued success thanks for being part
of this trip
thank you man take care jason
next up we have anna bogger president
and ceo
of out of home advertising association
of america
she recently joined in september of 2019
to spearhead the transformation anna was
named one of the 30 most powerful women
in mobile advertising by business
insider
six years in a row and the awards go on
and on
welcome anna thank you thank you so much
anna how are you i'm good i'm good how
are you gary
i'm well so you know let's just get
right into the meat of the conversation
since we have such
a little time how do you process the
question
where is the consumer's attention right
now um and
and what are your thoughts on that uh
well
i'm not kidding uh but i actually firmly
believe that the attention is outdoor of
course out of home
uh i do i do think that you know we just
recently did a survey with harris poll
looking at consumer
change and behavior since the pandemic
and i do think that consumers appreciate
more than ever being outside being out
of their homes
uh being out and about and that survey
kind of firmly showed that
uh 70 of americans say that they
appreciate the outdoor space
much more now than they did before and
uh that they really appreciate messages
out of home
uh and just seeing things that seem
familiar to the way the world was before
so i actually think consumer attention
is there
i think people have some i apologize
because i think that's interesting so i
get the idea of like backyard
go hiking you know take a run on the
street
am i incorrect this is a question am i
incorrect in thinking that most of the
billboards
or the the the out of home advertising
is predicated a little bit more around
transportation infrastructure
that the on the highways or the roads or
the subways
you know i the thought of going outside
for sure but
but those individuals that are doing
those activities
what's their likelihood of coming across
a billboard and then being in the
framework of consumption
since they'll be on their feet let's say
instead of a vehicle
well i mean i they're they may not be in
the woods even though i mean there's
something
exactly there actually in the woods too
any anything can be designed right but
but no i think you're right i think
we've changed our our behavior i think
most consumers are probably not
traveling as far
transit still you know a category about
a home that that has not as much
travelers even though
you know the new york transit has about
two million uh people coming through it
every day so we're
back to quite high levels still but you
know people do
um people do take the car to go shopping
or to go small errands
there's signage you know there's bus
shelters there's local signs you know
it's it's out of home it's not just
about roadside it's so much
just that so yes what i'm trying to
figure out based on the report you're
just talking about is the connection
between hey i want to be out more
because i've been stuck in my home
and the appreciation for outdoor
advertising what's the link there i
guess
i think that there is a link you know
again just being out and about and being
seeing signs and seeing science and not
science as the actual signage but
science and society that things are kind
of the way they were before
we saw in this survey that consumers
more than half of the consumers
overall say that they notice outdoor
advertising more now than they did in
the past and in urban areas 69
i think it was around 70 said that they
notice it more so i think it's
it's uh it's a sense of familiarity and
things being back to normal again
physical ads you know resonate more i
think than digital
physical more than digital well not
as digital within media or within
content right
right but but which is interesting
because the industry
and correct me if i'm wrong here the
digitalization of outdoor
is upon us so if there's a subtle
movement to
that's an interesting juxtaposition for
the industry i'm sure that's they're
trying to debate through right
well but that's a dif that's a
difference between digital
advertising and media right our signs
are digital which makes them much more
nimble
and in many ways more flexible but
they're still out in the physical
outdoors about being in a location where
consumers are for
for a number of different reasons using
triggers you know that
happens in that location whether it's
current events or weather or whatever it
is to serve an ad faster better so
digital
like is actually helping our medium a
lot i'm talking more about
ads that are out in the spaces that
consumers want to be in right now which
is not necessarily in their home
understood um what is the
what is the reality of the digital
json of or digitalization of outdoor
billboards it was a
tough one um is billboard owners
um are they gravitating quickly to that
because of the flexibility in the
target ability or or is the old guard
still holding firm and not wanting to go
that route what's kind of the state of
the union just out of my own curiosity
i would say first of all out of home is
about so much more than just billboards
i just want to clarify that it's signage
everywhere it's play space
billboards it's trans airport it's all
those things um
street furniture um no i think the whole
industry is
has pivoted to to more and more digital
and the pandemic can certainly help with
that
again you know the need for more
flexibility and nimbleness that
advertisers you know
really are looking for now has speeded
up that evolution in our industry i
think that's a really positive thing so
we're moving in that direction very fast
and what about um to your point
expanding outside of you know and and i
appreciate you correcting me a couple of
times because i think that's where my
mind defaults
the fact that it has so much breath than
just the classic
billboard on the highway what where is
the most interesting innovation around
consumer attention in your opinion
of you know the outdoor movement
what's kind of like if we're if we're
putting a billboard or a bus stop ad or
a bench or
uh in in the subway on the shelf over
here as things we've known
what is the biggest innovations that
you're seeing
well the area that i'm most interested
in and that's actually not something
that works so well on billboards at
least not on the highway but it's around
video
right our medium lends itself with these
really rich
screens that are in very great location
but locations where consumers sometimes
are just standing waiting for things
right like the bus stop or
or walking around in the city the fact
that our medium cannot just
not just provide rich media advertising
but actually also
content right that brands can you know
produce content that follows a consumer
around
uh you know build really interesting
stories i think that that's the most
interesting thing that are
or one of the most interesting things
that are happening in our medium right
now um
and an area you're really high growth
is that are there real estate owners
that are
are really innovating are you are you
having people that
are reaching out to you that are trying
to convert their physical
into advertising mediums are you hearing
from state parks from people that own
trees i'm trying to really take this
yeah out of home is very much about real
estate that's something that i learned
you know i've just been in this job for
one year and it's a big big part of the
medium it is about finding that right
location
and these real estate owners right um or
or advertising companies they're
specialists and finding the right
location and doing something interesting
with it
and if they have one they know about it
if they don't know about it somebody
else will come and ask them for it so
so there's definitely a lot of real
estate owners that are interested in
this and
it's a way to monetize a building that
you have and it doesn't have to be
digital i mean
another really interesting area of out
of home is just utilizing
wall sides wall scapes to create really
really beautiful
you know murals and paintings and things
like that anything you have that's in a
good location can really be used for
advertising
you know it's in a good way of course
they were kind of lost that upholding
right you can't digitize everything
on that front you said something there
that struck me i was just generally
curious because attention comes in a lot
of ways and
attention for a lot of people is maybe
career changes what
you said you've only been there for a
year what were you doing prior and what
was the
what was the thing that kind of tipped
you over and said heck i need to be the
president ceo of this organization
um well you know i thought it was really
really good timing for me actually that
the job sort of was on the market and i
was contacted about it i had spent
almost 10 years at the ib
uh building or the mobile video and data
operations there
um and i really like building and
growing things i'm a salesperson right
and my first seven years at the ibe was
all about that
then it become very much about
protecting and safeguarding the medium
and you know explaining why the medium
had value and worth
um out of home you know is is a medium
where
you can't block you can't skip you can't
you really kind of the ad is always
going to be there for the consumer to
see the experience for the consumer is
great
the medium had have experienced really
uh
massive growth of the past 10 years so
and that was sort of
now moving into the world is this the
enemy to the medium
no that's the best friend of the medium
the combination mobile out of home is
incredibly strong
you would agree with me that that
i actually want to break that down
because i'm very fascinated by that
because i think about
people in the subway not seeing the stop
ads or even within the subway because
like there's a lot of this going on so
what does the industry how does the
industry quant
quantify or think about it being the
best friend explain that point
well there's a combination right first
of all there's geo fencing and you know
you can sort of tie the mobile to the
odds
in a very effective way but but honestly
first of all
out of home is very much about landmarks
right so consumers will see
what you may think of of out of home may
not be what i think about a home like
there are
places that doesn't even look like an ad
where consumers want to share you know
so it's a strong connection to social
media so the big screen
will drive to the small screen but the
other way around too
and subway is an interesting example
static subway ads out of home ads
uh you know about 70 of the viewers that
see them actually then go and search for
that product on their phone
so it's the combination of having
something in your hand when you're out
and about that can make you connect to
that
to act on it yeah so so it's very
important then of course you know
there's
ways of targeting and tracking and
things like that that comes into that as
well so no
i would really call it the best friend
and that's really where my interests
spark too
early days of the ib i love it well
thank you so much we really appreciate
the conversation
thank you thank you for having me of
course thank you anna
our next guest is john helversen vp of
consumer experience at mondelez
international
john is a force to be reckoned with
having taken on
gnarly objective modules including
media roi personalization at scale and
world-class digital training
halo was at twitter as global director
of video strategy and ops and we can't
welcome you enough
ooh you're on you're on mute how though
thanks for having me it's great to see
you john john
let's get right into the meat because
you always have incredible insights
if i if i frame up where is the
consumer's attention
how do you take in that question and
what would you uh
have to say about that i think there's
two things i think
one the consumers got a lot more choice
out of this and i think i
really liked your conversation earlier i
was listening backstage is
it's not where the advertising dollars
are it's more importantly like the punch
line to that question is i don't think
advertisers are moving nimbly or fast
enough
necessarily responding to them and i
thought it was in i'm from the cpg
wasteland which you described earlier
so i found that discussion to be
interested like hey wait a second that's
me
but you know like but that's a huge
opportunity just like arbitraging
attention is a huge opportunity that
you've capitalized off of
i think not all cpgs not having
information
it does not have to be true one so i
think smart cpgs are building those
linked to retailers
and they're gonna kick the [ __ ] out of
the other guys so
i ultimately think that's a temporary
situation so
people have choice people are spending
their time in a lot of different places
i think
platforms maybe that's just where i'm
spending my time like i'm rediscovering
twitter in a way even though after
working there i think i toned out for a
while but i've been really found it
super helpful to get
up to speed quick i find people spending
more time in linkedin on that too
you know something just triggered for me
it was crazy for me that
that i've rediscovered wine in the last
three years
because i was always in wine then i left
it
and and i was just kind of like over it
i guess and then i rediscovered it it's
funny to hear
you do you feel that working at twitter
in some weird way
has enabled this rediscovery because you
did look at it from a different
perspective or was always around you and
as any human you needed to have
your attention go to other places when
you were yeah i think you have to shift
down then you shift back into it and you
just i just rediscovered what's
brilliant about it
i'd also say they've improved that a lot
too you know what i mean i think that
there's just the continual improvement
of those products
makes them better like i look at that
experience today versus when i was there
and i think that's remarkably better i
think linkedin has gotten a lot
better i mean if you remember when i was
at twitter it was a chronological
timeline my friend and that was you know
like
that was sacred ground so i think that
there's a lot of movement just
yeah it's just gotten smarter so i find
it just to be a useful tool
you know and maybe it's because it's
what i need in this time you know what i
mean it's like
i want to be smarter i feel a need to be
more current on these things
and i'm finding again linkedin and
twitter be tools to help me do it
since you're still at the forefront and
a major media executive talk to me about
podcasting and ott you know because i'm
jumping around here a lot but yeah
you know i don't keep podcasting so i'm
going to be the contrarian on this and
like
i've talked about this like in a lot of
categories i totally get it
i'm in food so i struggle a little bit
to get the same
like i love how my chocolate looks on
the screen and so
i love it on out of home boards i love
it on twitter does that mean that
mondelez doesn't do radio as well it's
all good
like listen globally gary i mean like
radio's less than one percent
and predominantly in italy to sell cream
cheese
all right like that's that's the radio
is not part of the mix and i would just
tell you it's never paid out from an roi
perspective
and yeah there's is it is it given the
chance to the conversation we had
earlier with jason right because
you know where i sit on this which is
what about an actual podcast isolated
test sending to krogers and seeing you
if you have lyft because i i have
empathy for why
no we've never we've never ground it out
as tight like we have in other things so
that's totally fair it's just when you
have an abundance of opportunity
elsewhere like what causes you to go do
this and what do you see as the upside
and to your point
podcasting exceeded all expectations i
think in certain categories
it's amazing and it's always in the
context of
here it's not part of my playbook i
could go to a different company i could
go to a different cpg
and it'd be like the core part of my
playbook and again
let's talk about that because i love you
for that statement i think that was as
good of a statement in this show so far
talk to me about the reverse engineering
of the reality of the business because i
think what you said there
again i'm always thinking about this
show because we have such a crazy mix of
listeners
from seven-year-old entrepreneurs to
board members of fortune 50 companies i
think what you just said there is a
amazingly universal how much is a media
exact do you think about
the context of where you're distributing
based on the business result because
what you just said is like hey
if i if i believe the medium worked for
me i thought that was a big
big point right there like is how
granular can you get there
we're talking to the macro how about you
think you have to be obsessed
i think you have to be obsessed like you
know the number one thing i would tell
you is like
you have a business strategy about how
you win and that has to go all the way
down into the media choices that you
make
because if you're gonna be
consumer-centric look at the companies
that really grow they're just obsessed
they're obsessed about their product and
you have to be equally obsessed about
your media
and ultimately the companies that do
well like look why do dtc's go because
they're obsessed they're looking at the
results every single day they're waking
up at 4 a.m after double click updates
and sends the new results and they're
updating creative so the people who are
the best are the ones who are obsessed
and you should care about it
like you i mean i'm just like it's what
gets me up in the morning like i put my
feet on the floor
at 5 00 a.m because i'm just like oh i
wonder what happened you know like
what's going on with it
what about the cultural overlay you know
you you work with some of the biggest
brands in the world
i think about oreo and that you know off
the top i had the supreme play or
or transformers like some of the ip like
what about the arbitrage of
culture and where the brands show up
i think that there's a few things one
you can never be
you know it's interesting like i think
about a continuum like again you have to
have a clear strategy about how you win
and i from an outside perspective like
let's talk about nike i
think what nike does so well they
understand how to be
in culture and the context and you build
skills to be able to do that that
doesn't just happen
you don't just wake up and be good at
that you have to be listening social
listening you have to have insights you
have to have
the right creative minds you have to
have people who are on top of that
on the other end of the spectrum there
are people who grow through
personalization and their way in is
through targeting and pieces and then
they target the specific people and then
they try and create relevance for it
i think that ultimately you have to have
a core
methodology and a dominant logic but you
have to be willing to play other
opportunities when you see it and again
oreo does a lot of really great
personalized marketing that's on this
side but then they have these pops like
things like what we did
with uh most recently around lgbt game
of thrones
uh tweets in the dark that ultimately
just create relevance for the brand that
enable all of this other stuff to work a
lot harder
and so you have to have a dominant logic
and a strategy it's people who don't
have a strategy though like look what
where i struggle with a lot of cpg they
play it down the middle
one day they start being cultured the
next day they think they want to be the
greatest at personalization the next day
they want to do this like
you have to have a strategy and a
methodology because it'll determine the
people you recruit it'll determine the
capabilities you build
the agencies you hire you know like why
aren't your
meeting agency because you're good at
this like how how hard is it to get a
big big big organization like you you
know it's it's when i hear you talk i'm
like it's really easy when i start small
companies
vayner empathy like you you know what
about at the scale that you're playing
globally
what does it require in leadership to go
to a totally different place
to take bets on where attention has
emerged
you know when i i know enough about your
career you
for big company stuff big you know
you've been able to be to places pretty
damn early it's one thing when i've been
to places early
i have no i don't have the check you
know the handcuffs
you've had of a great track record of
being to places much earlier than the
other things that are
of your size and i think you've been
able to navigate and that's why you've
had the successful career
what does it take to get big companies
to those new places before reporting
has kicked in and common sense is the
currency
or is that even the play no i mean it's
very much the play i mean i think that
ultimately
what it takes to do that is one you have
to get in and you have to make a
strategic assessment of the situation so
you just got to look around and say look
how do we win right and think about
different companies you run like even if
you're an entrepreneur startup
are we going to be high margin and sell
a few or are we going to be low margin
and sell a whole lot
right like there's a dominant logic as
to how you win so then you have to just
like in media you have to make an
assessment and say okay
what are we like you know what type of
company are we what are our core
competencies how what
what's our philosophy for how about how
our brands grow
and ultimately you have to like put
those statements down and have a
manifesto
and know what you don't believe you know
what i mean like with us
mass communication is done we think it's
a single digit thing
you know the dominant logic of cpg of
mass communications
when i got here in 2017 we said we think
that's a low single digit growth
opportunity not all that interested
we'll be a part of the mix yeah but it's
not the focus it's not where we're gonna
invest
we're throwing out ubiquity auditing we
don't really care how we do this we
don't care how we do this because that's
part of that world then what you have to
have you have to have a narrative
like ultimately you have to have a
thesis that you can take to people that
stirs their hearts and their minds
and that because once you scale that
across the organization
then people will know what you're doing
because you cannot be everywhere
like you gary can't be everywhere in
your company but yet people know
like hey here are the principles these
are the guidelines
and i think what's important about that
i had a real revelation on this this
week
is the reason why guidelines are
important and like boundaries
is because if you give people boundaries
they will run to them
whereas if you don't they will stay safe
in the center
they're ultimately not going anywhere
and so when you say look this is your
decision rights they will sprint out and
fill that whole spirit
they're crippled by too much open
because it becomes fearful it's like
fully
psychological safety like it's like call
the ball
john i can do this for 40 hours but
since this was 10 minutes it was a real
pleasure thank you so much for that
explosion of energy
all right thank you helvo
next we want to welcome bob pittman he's
the ceo and chairman of i heart radio
the number one audio company in america
bob was the co-founder and programmer
behind all things mtv and he's the
co-founder
and original lead investor in casa
dragones tequila
the good stuff i love that that was in
there bob it's great to see you
good seeing you thank you sir speaking
about consumer attention
i i do think the iconic nature you know
i want to speak about the audio stuff
in a big way but i do think between i
heart
you know between playing such a major
role in the current state
of podcasting but also being at the
forefront
of mtv what's what's the similarity
in what you learned in the mid-80s there
in building that dominant force of
attention
and and sitting at one of the seats at
the precipitous of the current attention
graph around audio
any common themes that can link that
that could be pattern recognition for
the audience
sure i think what you're doing is you're
looking at what what do people need
what's been overlooked
uh mtv was really about you had a
generation that had grown up with tv and
grown up with
music and the two had never come
together rock music so we put them
together and what we figured out
was that we were never going to make
music for the tv form
so we made tv fit the music form and we
made
mtv the star not the pieces of it we
weren't a delivery system like a
broadcast network
and what we became was we came in the
heart of the culture
and what we figured out is how do we get
people talking about us how do we become
part of the culture
by the way i did it again at aol with
steve case when we did aol was
in my day in the 90s we had 50 of the
traffic of the internet the us went
through aol
and we were aol instant messenger we
were sort of the facebook and google
combined of that period and indeed
my last deal was to give google the
search traffic of aol which gave them
their their critical mass
and i think i heart's been the same
thing i mean what we spotted was that
and i
was interesting listening to to your
previous guest
and talking about radio i'm not sure you
gotta grasp what it is
what radio really is and what audio and
what podcasting is
it's again it's a consumer idea every
time i do something i'm you know i would
say
well i said it's convenience in a box
what we're doing is we're making
everybody's life easier
by using this thing called the internet
to save them time
with with uh with i heart what we're
doing is we realize
people are desperate for companionship
especially in this world in which we're
all taking our phones and staring at
them like this on the street
is we are looking for somebody to keep
us company
and by the way ryan seacrest is a great
friend there's so many
people in the morning they listen to
them when they're in the shower
he's entertaining them and talking to
them while they're brushing their teeth
they rides to work with them and that's
the way and by the way
charlemagne the god elvis duran bobby
bones
pick yours and to me that's the big idea
and why i got so
interested in it and i think radio was
sort of lost in oh but it's am
fm it's not it's wherever the listeners
are with the products and services they
expect we're on smart tv
smart speakers around 250 other
platforms
and to me podcasting is the equivalent
of what netflix was for tv
it's sort of radio on demand or things
that could have been on the radio
and that's sort of all it is and it's no
surprise
probably that mpr and iheart
are the two big podcasters by about 2x
to the next largest
uh and we have this sort of flywheel
going
that people hear about stuff on the
radio they check it out on podcasting we
cycle them through
in and out you know what's so crazy
about this combo
the written word pictures video
and audio communication will be here in
perpetuity
in different shapes and formats in
different distributions
and by the way and we've seen this you
know the 1940s and 50s boxing
horse racing baseball people radio was
dominant then the video creation came
then the internet came it all evolves
and they'll all have their moments
right so by the way what's interesting
is if you look at the consumer
radio's never left it reaches about 92
percent of americans oh none of it's
left
forever so all you're talking about is
not
with ads and for fads and advertising
not with the consumer but
i think that's i will fit this bob i do
think i agree with all that comma
i do think when the mobile device comes
along and creates radio
in your pocket i do think there are
subtle moments of distribution
i do think as you know when you look at
the evolution the distribution
of video with a laptop that i have right
now accelerate i do think things
distribute differently well we had we
had a transistor radio
in the 1960s you're too young to weren't
there it looked
a lot like this i was a small man guy it
was a little thicker now the transistor
radio was a lot thicker but it was about
that size
and it opened up mobility and so i
i think what you find is at the end of
the day look i've sold people a lot of
stuff and i've created some big brands
i've turned around six flags theme park
century 21 real estate casa dragonis
tequila
um you know it's i love doing this but
what
always is important is we need word of
mouth
we need people talking about us not
showing it when we say i want my mtv
people don't come and say
let me show you a picture of mtv they
tell their friend have you heard about
mtv it's great
they're using words they're using a
conversation
if you want culture it's 100
about somebody telling you something i
know we've arrived
when we're the topic of a dinner table
conversation and if we're not
i haven't arrived and what i often use
advertising for like i want my mtv
i need to prime the pump prime the pump
of word of mouth i gotta get people
talking about me
what can i do and that's the holy grail
i think in making something big
biggest buyer of what you just said when
you think about distribution
getting that message in the right places
and when you think about the content
the thing that fills that pipe when you
go for that
being talked about at the dinner table
in the distribution
are you know of the moment and the
content that fails it
how do you see the 100 energy of getting
that right
which which takes the lead is it even
steven
when you personally think about where
you're distributing the message and what
the message is
to get to the dinner table how do you
break down a hundred just by the way
for us it's easy they're a billion
radios in america
whether 250 million smartphones 120
million 150 million computers
uh we have a device advantage now
not resting on our laurels we also said
you know what there are times when
people don't have that
you pointed it out here it is so i want
to be
everywhere and our strategy is be
everywhere our listeners are with the
products and services they expect
and so we we've done some research when
you talk to young people we had this
you know one of these stories you tell
again and again a couple of years ago
we're doing all these focus groups and
talking to
young people and talking about radio and
they kept looking like this
and i said what's going on you're giving
us a weird look finally they go why are
you calling it radio
that's just the device that's a thing i
said what would you call this if i call
it z100
i call it elvis duran and i guess you're
right and it's sort of
that moment sort of like aha freed us
from the fact that the consumer doesn't
is agnostic on devices by the way they
think this is a radio somehow in here
uh they don't understand it's using the
internet blah blah blah blah
it's just like turn it on i can see 100
there and get it on my smartphone
yeah alexa c100 for me um it's
works and so i and then when you talk
about content
we're the most unusual medium you can
think of because our content
is actually not linear it's not story
arc it's not the normal kind
it is companionship i'm another human
being who will keep you company
by the way how valuable is that very
valuable by the way during covet we saw
it was even more important
by the way come after a tornado after a
a hurricane
everybody's on the radio and we're not
doing music programming we're telling
people where to get blankets
in houston when there was flooding we
were on the air and people were calling
us on the phone telling us where they
were
and we were telling people with boats
how to get to them
to rescue them i apologize i have a huge
question because we have one minute
sure the only thing i've been thinking
these whole nine minutes
even though you've been dropping
fundamental gems
on content and distribution and
attention graph is
how the [ __ ] does this guy not have his
own radio show his voice was [ __ ]
built for [ __ ] podcasting bob by the
way
literally the voice listen listen to
math and magic
stories from the frontiers of marketing
i do my own podcast it's about marketing
you will love it and you've now agreed
you don't know it come on and be a guest
it's done brother it's great to see you
thanks appreciate it bye-bye
thank you bob andrea real quick i know
you need to read the thing but like
bob's voice is insane i know isn't it
crazy i was like listening i'm like wait
a minute this is a
tremendous it's so funny that's what all
the comments are saying too
i love it why don't you bob i love it i
love it i was a dj as a teenager so
there you go go ahead andrea all right
next up we've got a different kind of dj
in alicia tillman the global cmo of sap
who is the boss alicia was named the
11th
most influential cmo i want to meet the
other 10 who could they possibly be
and for and most importantly she is a
jersey girl
through and through welcome alicia
thank you hi thanks andrea hey gary
hey alicia it's so nice to see you you
too
talk to me we're going to go right into
the meet because you always have such
great insights um
consumer attention you know with sap
being such an iconic b2b business i'm
actually going to start there because
i'm trying to
fill a lot of different voids help a lot
of people who are listening go a lot of
different places
from a b2b standpoint trying to you know
it's very different than trying to get
somebody
to download the iheart app and listen to
some music or to sell some oreos
you're selling sometimes seven
eight-figure contracts
um how do you think about and and by the
way what i know about the b2b
world is a lot of conferences a lot of
big boots
that b2b a lot of sales dna more than
marketing and branding dna
where do you see the attention of the
b2b con
decision maker your potential customer
for all the b2b heads that are in here
how are you thinking about current
attention graphs uh
and where their attention is i mean i
think it's pretty simple
and you know i'll say i don't think it's
much different from
how we need to market to consumers
especially in the environment we're in
right now
at the end of the day it's about the
story you tell
i could be selling box cereal to
enterprise software to how to get
attention on mtv
it is about the story the relevance the
emotion
how well it connects that's what it's
all about
and if you don't have a narrative and
you don't have a brand that's anchored
in
purpose and things people care about
you need to believe that if i'm a cfo or
a cmo or a cio or whatever c level
at an organization more and more
people are buying with their hearts
their values
even if it's meaning they're buying
technology
to service a part of their business
they're not going to buy technology from
a company that doesn't share in their
values
and isn't contributing to help make the
world a better place it's what it's all
about it's about value relevancy and
purpose
and what about where you're distributing
those messages and in what content
you know i think the thing that i'm
thinking a lot about is i couldn't agree
with that more so now what's the
manifestation from a production
standpoint
and which channels you know so much of
this is the contemporary 2021 as we head
into 2021
what are the channels that you think are
emerging as better deals for your money
and what are some of the ones that are
start that you're that you and your
partners start to look around and be
like do you really want to write a
million dollar check for x y and z
so it's all about community and how do
you create
forums that allow people to be part of
the discussion i mean
look at this community that we're in
right now you and i are having a
conversation
and you see the chat where others are
participating in the conversation as
well and that's what it's about it's
how do i get access to you how do i
become part of the conversation
how can i tell you the value that i need
so that you can actually shape a product
for me
so i not only come in and buy it but i
come back time and time again because i
know that you're listening to me
and so video chat
any type of interactive media
where your buyers can feel as though
they have that access to you to be able
to shape the way you're thinking
in terms of the innovation around the
products and services that you create
that's where i think the future is
headed
static communications sure it can tell a
story
but people don't get a chance to react
to that live
and there's too many opportunities today
otherwise that will allow for that and
that's what people want they want to be
part of it they want to shape it
and i think that that's what's going to
be the most meaningful as we head into
the future
you're sitting as as a cmo one of the
biggest companies in the world
trying to again bring this program to
all my different constituents there's a
lot of
young women trying to get into marketing
right now that are probably listening
how should they be thinking about
getting i mean you how do they get to
your spot like how did it
you know what are the things that you
learned the do's the don'ts there's so
much serendipity i know there's a lot of
things that go into it but
if you're really trying to mentor uh
some of the young men and women who are
listening right now about
to get to this level of marketing
how do you think about that i would say
that
it's actually i would focus on the
things that
don't typically appear on a resume in
fact i actually think the entire resume
needs to be rewritten
because yes it's important that you have
experience and
and what you've delivered but i think
what's even more experienced certainly
at my level
is how well of a communicator are you
how much empathy do you have how much do
you value a diverse and inclusive
workplace how much care and attention do
you give to employees when they need it
most
especially during a global pandemic when
mental health and wellness is at an
all-time low
those are the things that really
matter when it comes to operating at the
top
the top of your company the top of the
function in which you lead
when you think about developing
something new being an entrepreneur
those are the things that set you apart
you know i had a conversation this
morning
with with someone that i'm mentoring and
you know she
said to me i don't really have the
experience and i don't know how i'm
going to get it and i said you know what
i want you to focus on
is that energy you're bringing to me
right now do not
lose that passion that energy
this belief that you can change things
because we don't have enough of that
we have a lot of things why do you
apologize why do you think people fear
because i don't think i think there's a
lot of things in life that have failed
people
um and i think people do i apologize do
you think
that the way school is structured in
society
that you have to like play within these
rules to get this achievement i've been
thinking so much about this because
you're touching on company i care a lot
about
and i'm like why are you doing this and
somebody said to me that's all i know
like
do well for 90 days get a report card
too often like like
you know do you think that the rigidness
of education
has led to a lot of its fear in
corporate i've always thought that
you know you need a certain level of
education and then you need to go out in
the real world
and then you need to actually go back to
education again do you think
do you think you and i grew up in an era
where education was overvalued because
the real life stuff wasn't
as big of a conversation and yes i do
too
they don't teach you the soft skills
that are necessary
there's not enough interaction
that helps form your social skills your
leadership skills
sure they teach you the fundamentals of
how to lead a marketing program and
those things are necessary
but does it teach you how to be an
empathetic person and alicia
what about what about the fact that a
lot of the teachings on how to build a
brand
or thing of that nature we're in a
television top down world as the
internet's staring us in the face
i mean even that teaching i mean i'm
devastated
when i talk to some kids coming out of
like real brand school i'm like
this is what they're teaching absolutely
you're
you're absolutely right there are
differences
on so many levels and you've got to
think about
when and where you apply the right
tactics to the right things based on
what matters
to that point in time or that person
that you're talking to and so
it is so nuanced to just so varied
and you have to have the empathy
the the ability to listen to then go out
and sort of
react to what it is you need to bring
to what people want and how well do you
absorb that and shape something in
response
is in my view what's going to set the
great leaders apart from those
that are not seen as the best leaders of
their time
alicia you have to tell me a huge secret
i've been doing the show for months
we've rebooted it i like this format by
the way as we're wrapping up please
everybody leave i see all the comments
how do you like this 10 minute rapid
format versus the other one please leave
that comment
but i have a massive question
you have the best lighting
that i've seen from any guest on this
show and i think a lot of people drock's
laughing in the back
uh but what is that you i mean you must
exp i mean
am i right i mean your writing is insane
alicia thank you
no thank you i have a i have a beautiful
light right in front of me
um that helps like we need good lighting
goldie hawn told me a year ago when i
met her that the secret to life
is good lighting by the way
[Music]
by the way it's you know what just made
me like
smile in my heart for you and i and
andrea and a certain percentage of this
audience that goldie hein reference was
such a huge flex humblebrag for a whole
other poison
of our audience like anyway thank you so
much continued success
we love you yeah a lot of people don't
know is vaynermedia and sap are in the
same building
in manhattan so we love sharing the
building with you continued success
and i love sitting with an award winner
here by the way congratulations agency
of the year you guys completely
deserve that and keep rocking it because
you guys deserve it
thank you bye thank you
well gary i like this format what'd you
think
yeah i think should we do it again
again let's talk about it i'm going to
talk to your audience about it i think i
need you to
i have a little sleeping i have to tell
your audience yeah
i'm sorry i'm confused you want me to
leave yeah i'm gonna need you to leave
for a second i have
a couple questions i need to just ask
them without you here
okay all right bye everyone we'll see
you later please levi hi gary
but hold on andrew let me just say
goodbye i mean i'm not
do you know what they're doing um thanks
everybody for watching this week
please leave uh some comments on twitter
right now i'm gonna go there while i go
to my next meeting
to just get a sense of the format i was
following along
um you know 10 minutes i know i'm trying
to get to some places so like classic i
i had to interrupt here and there but i
didn't want to
but i thought we got a lot out of this i
like the single format theme questions
please give me some feedback on that
andrea have fun with whatever the heck
you're up to
we'll talk to you later bye everyone
thank you gary all right everybody
we're going to have a surprise birthday
party for gary vaynerchuk
and it's going to be on november 19th
thursday november
19th from 12 to 2 p.m
so i'm hoping you can all join me to
send some
birthday wishes and all the rest um and
if you'd like to get an invitation get
everything put on your calendar get some
of our marketing newsletters
please fill out our form it's on all
things social everywhere that we are
so go fill out one of those forms and
we'll get you all the information
keep the conversation alive at marketing
for the now let us know what you thought
about this format and we will see you
on november 19th bye-bye